PROFESSOR: So having
established the importance
of airborne transmission in
the spreading of COVID-19
specifically, and more
generally in the spreading
of respiratory
pathogens, let's proceed
to analyze airborne transmission
in a well-mixed room.
So we're thinking
of a situation where
a certain number of people
are sharing an indoor space.
And the air in that room
is well-mixed enough
that as pathogen-containing
droplets are released
from the breath of one
person, it's quickly spread
throughout the whole room.
And by the time someone
else breathes it,
they're essentially exposed
to the average concentration of
pathogen in the air
after accounting
for such effects as the
settling, the evaporation,
the ventilation, filtration,
and other effects,
but still at the level
of a well-mixed space.